you don't need money to launch your
business I can't tell you how many times
people write in to me they message me
they call my radio show and they ask me
how do I get the five thousand dollars
the fifty thousand dollars the five
hundred thousand dollars to launch my
business because until that happens I
can't do anything and that's so wrong
you don't need money to start your
business
you don't need resources you don't need
an office
you don't need partners you don't need
anything you don't need a website to
start your business all you need is
yourself and your resourcefulness
because being an entrepreneur is going
up against impossible odds and having
people tell you you're never gonna make
it and we constantly starved of
resources and you find a way to make it
happen and if you're the kind of person
who's just sitting on an idea because
you don't have money coming in nobody's
back in your project and that prevents
you from starting you're not gonna be
successful you have to find a way to
start this thing up now this comes as a
result of a question from our YouTube
viewer love you guys Kareem Kareem
writes in to saying I have a board game
I came up with but the only manufacturer
I could find once $5,000 a month facture
my game and then I have to worry about
marketing how would you suggest how
would you suggest I get that going so
Kareem you don't need the $5,000 don't
go out and spend money I don't want you
taking $5,000 out of your bank account
out of your savings boring it from
friends and family don't do that to
launch this business you don't need that
you need to find a way to make money
before you're spending it this is a
critical rule stop spending money until
you're making money there's a lot of
ways you can get this thing going start
getting some pre-orders go to Facebook
create a campaign use your social media
use your friends use your contacts go on
Kickstarter
okay you have another Kickstarter go to
Kickstarter comm you can post your idea
there and people will essentially
pre-order your product you say I'm
making this board game here's what it's
all about and this will take care of
your funding and also take care of your
marketing at least in the startup phase
and it'll give you feedback as to
whether people think this is a great
idea or not if you put this idea up on
Kickstarter and you explain everything
and you're passionate in your video and
you explain what this board game is
meant to do and why it's so great and
nobody buys it the market might be
telling you something because here's
what most people do most people are
thinking of a product they'll go out and
they'll make it and they'll take a loan
out or they'll cash out their savings to
make this product and it sits in their
garage they try to sell it nobody buys
it and they're just sitting on inventory
in their apartment in their garage in
their basement that they don't know what
to do with and they're stuck paying this
loan every month back and I don't want
that to be you you have to show to
yourself that you have a winning idea
and you have to start generating some
momentum with it and some pre-orders on
your concept before you go out and
actually make it it's great that you
want on you casa de tout okay so you
know it's gonna cost you five K to
manufacture it but lots of people can
manufacture it the harder part is the
marketing getting sales and you don't
need to have the finished product to
start getting some sales on it you can
get pre-orders and you need people to
show you that this is a great idea
before you start investing your own
money and your savings into it it's so
important it's teaching you a great
lesson for everything as you continue
growing this business up and for all of
you watching stop spending money
because you end up spending it's a real
problem you end up spending all your
money on this thing
whatever idea you have and I get that
you know you're the only one who
believes in this thing and you want to
make this happen
and nobody's supporting you and so you
cash out what if you have to invest into
the company but I don't want you to go
bankrupt on this thing and there may be
a way better way to launch this thing or
maybe we better features to add to it
more completely different concept
altogether and you won't have anything
to help you get through it and you'll be
stuck paying off this crushing debt for
the rest of your life potentially and I
don't want that for you we want you to
be successful I want you to be happy I
want you to change the world through
your products and services
so stop spending money until you're
making money believe for those of you
watching you like the video thumbs up
below let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath you have a question
for me I'll make a video response if you
ask your question below thank you so
much and I'll see you soon